- Elle m'a fait vraiment mal.
C'est comme si je m'étai       .
- Laure Warda se souvient bien
de ce qui devait être un simple
examen gynécologique de routinee
qu'elle a eu mal pendant
une semaine.
LAURE WARDA
ce n'est pas agréable et j'en a,
en effet, c'est inconfortable,
qu'on gratte un peu la paroiérét
vraiment pire.
au moment des questions posées
m m m médecin, particulièrement
lorsqu'elle lui a confié avoir
eu usexuels pendant l'année.
- Elle m'a regardé et me dit
juste : "En tous cas, t'es
occupée." Puis j'ai trouvé ça...
Moi,une poubelle, à ce moment-l.
Il y a pas d'autres mots.
- À l'époque, Laure Warda
ne comprenait pas ce qui s'était
passaujourd'hui : c'était de
la violence gynécologique,
des gestes, des propos ou
des pratiques aux formes
trèdes conséquences significatis
sur les femmes.
- C'est les paroles qui m'ont
le plus blessé. Le jugement
que
mis très, très mal à l'aise.
- Les personnes qui ont vécu
des VOG, ça dure une vie.
- Lorraine Fontaine travailleaus
de 20 ans. Aucun chiff
n'existe sur les violences
gynécologiques et obstauauauauat
que c'est plus commun
que l'on croit.
LORRAINE FONTAINE, DG Regrisisis
- Quelle est l'ampleur
au Québec? On ne le sait pas.
On ne peut pas mesurer. On pvovd
des centaines de témoignages.
- On entend les femmes avoir
eu des expériences malheureusesd
s'intéresse à la question depuis
près de cinq ans. Elle offre
de la formation sur le sujetoroe
d'un consentement éclairé.BEBEÉD
obstétricienne-gynécologue
- C'est en faisant de
l'éducation dans nos milieux
Dre DIANE FRANCOEUR, DG, Société
obstétriciens,olololologues, CAN
- Notre position est très claire
par rapport à cet état de
et mettre tout en oeuvre
pour que ça cesse.
- Et selon la docteure
Francoeur, ça passe aussi
par de la sensibilistetetetetet.
- Il faut encourager les femmes
iriririr... à nous dire leurs
secrets. Il faut que les femmes
n'aient pas peur de le dire.
- Moi, à l'époque, j'ai été
sonnée, puis je l'ai mis d
un tiroir de ma tête de toutes
les expériences un peu
trau q q q q q q q q q q q q q .
Et j'étais comme : "ah, c'est
pas grave, ça arrive, elle était
juste pas délicate". Puis, bien
là, c'est comme, le réveil supup
d'autres femmes.
- Car ice e e e ailleurs dans
le monde, de plus en plus
de femmes dénoncent les mauvais
d'examen. En France, ces jours-
ci, c'est la secrétaire d'Éta
et gynécologue Chrysoula
Zacharopoulou qui se retrouve
sur la selleplplplplplplplplplp.
Laure Warda songe elle aussi
à porter plainte contre
la médecin qui l'a traitée
pour p
patientes, dit-elle.
Ici Kim Vermette,
Radio-Canada, Montréa